at Apple we design products that change  people's lives we believe in the power  of values to shape history and we strive  to live those values every single day we  believe the country that made our  success possible should be the land of  opportunity for every American that's  why we support President Obama's Connect  ed initiative to equip underserved  schools with cutting-edge technologies  it's why we're committed to hiring  American suppliers and it's why we're  manufacturing more of our products and  components in the United States in fact  our products and innovations so far have  led to the creation of more than 1  million American jobs in all 50 states  we believe in leaving the world better  than we found it and that's why we're on  track to meet our goal of running our  entire company on renewable energy thank  you